so beginnt sie ihren tag so fitschen
könnte einen zwei meter mann ko schlagen
aber darum geht es nicht
watson ist eigentlich ein sehr
technischer spart das eigentlich sehr
komplex das sieht auf den ersten blick
vielleicht gar nicht so aus aber da gibt
es unterschiedliche schläge und man kann
richtig oder falsch treffen das merkt
man auch sehr sehr schnell und für mich
verein boxen auch sozusagen die
kombination zwischen power und kraft und
ausdauer in männerdomänen einzubrechen
gehört zu ihrem leben
ich persönlich ich würde mir wünschen
dass es dass es mehr frauen gibt die
kampfsport betreiben egal ob das jetzt
boxen ist oder karate die welt braucht
auf jeden fall mehr weibliche choice und
mehr weibliche steve jobs startup
gründerinnen wie sie sind eher die
ausnahme
jung ist eigentlich ärztin seit 2005 10
betreibt sie eine plattform für
medizintourismus die weltweit patienten
an kliniken vermittelt 40.000 waren es
nach eigenen angaben bislang im
gegensatz zu anderen frauen trauten sie
sich zu eine firma zu gründen
also ich würde mir wünschen dass frauen
mutiger sind oft in vielen situationen
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger
selbstkritik und selbstzweifel an sich
ausüben und sich ab und zu auch einfach
einen stärkeren rückgängen sich zutrauen
auch mal in die welt raus zu gehen und
etwas zu gründen die größte hürde beim
gründen geld von investoren eintreiben
wollte von ihnen 1,7 millionen euro
haben und schaffte es dank ihres
selbstbewussten auftretens aber vor
allem dank ihrer überzeugungskraft
man muss seinen team überzeugen
motivieren
man muss mögliche zukünftige geldgeber
überzeugen und motivieren eben diese
investitionen zu tätigen auch an diese
unternehmen zu glauben dass man über
überzeugen muss und das muss man können
und da ist ganz sicher eine der stärken
von suchen gutes alphamännchen
schriftgutes alphaweibchen und arbeitet
als team zusammen tun hatte zuvor als
unternehmensberaterin gearbeitet
wenn man grunde hat man mit sehr viel
widerstand zu tun
man hat eine riesen verantwortung die
man tragen muss man muss jeden tag
entscheidungen fällen und da braucht man
schon ein hai aus stahl pause im park
mit den angestellten
das gehört auch zum firmenalltag neben
durchgearbeiteten nächten und ungewisser
perspektive
beides schmeckt so weist schon frauen
von gründen ab weibliche vorbilder so
meint sie könnten ängste vertreiben es
lange definitiv an vorbildern das sehe
ich bei mir selbst es gibt kaum eine
erfolgreiche gründer frau zu der ich
persönlich aussehen kann oder an der ich
mir ein beispiel nehmen kann und dass es
ja mit vielen sachen im leben so wenn es
keine vorbilder gibt wenn es weniger
menschen gibt die das vorleben wie es
funktioniert dann kann man sich das als
junger mensch teilweise auch nicht gut
vorstellen und da verlässt einen ab und
zu auch der mut fast die hälfte der
angestellten sind frauen
zufall sagt die chefin frauen werden im
unternehmen nicht bevorzugt